[Music]
the war in ukraine continues but in this
week's fyi we learned that children in
russia are being told there isn't a war
and from inside the conflict we have an
exclusive report from nadia she is one
of the thousands of children who was
forced to take shelter
i got scared at first i didn't
understand what was going on
and we meet the ukrainian children who
live in the uk who are helping refugees
this is fyi your weekly news show now
imagine we told you that there's no war
going on in ukraine and that it's all
rubbish would you believe us well that's
what children in russia are being told
we've been investigating how fake news
and misinformation is being used by the
russian government and why
since the russian president vladimir
putin decided to invade ukraine
he has never admitted to starting a war
he claims that he sent in troops as part
of a special security operation world
leaders have dismissed his claims saying
that president putin had started an
illegal full-scale invasion of an
independent country it now seems the
russian authorities are trying to
mislead people living in russia by using
propaganda videos and news bulletins
propaganda is a bit like fake news it's
misleading information to create a
particular opinion
we found a video that is being aimed at
children to convince them that there
isn't a war in ukraine
we are talking about the events in
ukraine the russian ministry of
education video is presented by a famous
12 year old russian singer who is joined
by adult presenters
the ukraine crisis didn't start
yesterday and it is not just about
ukraine there are many images about a
war in ukraine but actually these are
from other war conflicts
some images are even from computer games
as well as trying to convince russians
that the footage of the invasion is fake
the russian government is shutting down
radio and tv stations that have reported
the truth
this is the moment that staff from a tv
station had to walk offset after their
final broadcast they claimed the russian
government closed them down because they
referred to the ukraine invasion as a
war
now the russian people only have access
to government-run tv and radio stations
social media platforms and news stations
outside russia like the bbc are being
blocked from broadcasting in the country
many russians are against their
country's invasion of ukraine but those
who turn out on the streets to protest
are being arrested
all because they said no to war
[Music]
if you want to find out more about why
russia invaded ukraine and how world
leaders are trying to bring a peaceful
end to the war check out our i don't get
it explainer just head to our webpage
first.news fyi there are still many
ukrainians trying to flee the country
but it's getting more difficult
day after day russia has promised
ceasefires so that refugees could leave
towns and cities safely but in many
cases the fighting has continued in an
exclusive report nadia wanted to share
her story on fyi she is safe now but at
the start of the invasion nadi was being
treated in children's hospital in the
capital city kiev
nadia was in the middle of receiving
cancer treatment in hospital when she
heard the news about the war
the beginning of the war for me all
started when i woke up at about six in
the morning my mum was lying on the bed
next to mine and watching something
loudly
i got up and grabbed my phone
i saw that my friend was writing
something to me
and instead of good morning nadia she
wrote
nadia the war
i live near the airport it was blown up
by russian soldiers
i got scared at first i didn't
understand what was going on
i thought is this true or not
i went back into the room and i saw
zelensky was saying something on tv
my mum was watching and she was like
don't worry everything will be fine
and i understood that things are no
longer good
and i started shaking a little like this
i laid down on my bed and tried to fall
asleep
knowing that something was wrong
i heard some kind of strange sound i
said mum can you hear that there's some
noise outside the window
nothing exploded everything was fine
just terrible sirens
a nurse came up and said take the most
important documents your passport
maybe if the siren doesn't stop
screaming we'll have to go down to the
basement we'll take all sorts of things
downstairs just in case something
happens things like food water
mattresses they took everything
as the war escalated nadia and her
mother were then stuck in the hospital
basement for 10 days
only a couple of days before all this i
was sitting and telling my mum my plans
i said mum we will be released from
hospital on monday also then we'll go
home and take the money and buy me some
watercolors some other paints and all
sorts of canvas
after an emergency evacuation some of
the patients at the children's hospital
are now on their way to safety
nadia is heading to a hospital in italy
where she can continue receiving
treatment
refugee charities save four to seven
million ukrainian people are expected to
flee the fighting in ukraine
with just a few belongings many are
escaping to neighboring countries that's
moldova romania hungary slovakia and the
majority are heading into poland
but what do you do when you leave your
home and everything you have behind well
refugees and those trying to help them
wanted to share their story on fyi
[Music]
more than a million ukrainians have fled
to poland since the russian president
vladimir putin decided to invade ukraine
we met a student called kate near the
border between the two countries and she
explained how worried she was about the
family members she'd had to leave behind
i tried to
text them every day every hour because
they're very scary message from news
channels in kiev it's like
a key over bombs
it's very scary
there's been a lot of criticism that the
uk government hasn't done enough to help
the refugees come in here with
complaints that the process is too slow
and too difficult
but the people of poland have been
praised for rushing to help ukrainian
refugees
at the border crossing we met zuzana who
is part of the polish scouts and one of
the thousands of polish people who are
helping out
so we are organizing them places where
they can sleep or rest and we're giving
them food coats or things that they're
needed for them
but it's not just at the border that
people have been helping out families
all over poland have been offering to
give refugees a place to stay
hello fyi my name is gabrielle i'm from
krakow in poland
is just 240 kilometers away from ukraine
one of the things i love about this
place is that everyone is so friendly
and welcoming
so when we saw people fleeing here from
ukraine we knew we had to act
it was important for me and for them
because they had to rest and talk about
what to do next
i am very sorry that everything has been
ruined
[Music]
all the refugees who came to find a new
home in poland
some of these people have seen truly
horrible things on the way to my city
they are very worried about their
families who were left in ukraine to
fight
the family who've been staying with us
have now got a new home in katowice
we are taking them supplies to help them
establish themselves
the least we can do is open our homes
and our hearts the people of ukraine
because they do need our help
these are our neighbors
and they really need our support
[Music]
there are thousands of ukrainian
children that live in the uk
many of them have friends or family
either still in ukraine or trying to
flee their homeland understandably
they're super worried about them
every saturday lots of young ukrainians
go to saint mary's ukrainian school in
london
they told fyi about the things they're
doing to help their families and the
people of ukraine
[Music]
we're trying to support ukraine in any
way we can from here in england
it's important in the fact that there
are people dying there are people
struggling it's not just the fact that
it's our country as friends as family
but it's also there's people living in
bomb shelters people
under attack and it's basically our duty
to help them
i grew up in ukraine i was born there i
spent like most of my childhood there
so it's very close to my heart and it
hurts to see somewhere i grew up to be
destroyed
it's just being destroyed and
we've
done nothing to like deserve that
we need to
remember all the people right now in
ukraine
and what they're going through right now
we're all worried about our
other family members in ukraine maybe
something happens to them
and
we don't know
my grandma called me today and said that
she could go out to buy some things
like they have a siren that tells them
when they can go out and where they have
to stay in
we've been making posters and making
these ribbons that we could just show to
the public to raise awareness i've been
in school today and we've been doing
some
stuff to raise money to help ukraine
[Music]
we made a poster with all of the main
parts of ukraine just to show like we
want them to stay in ukraine because
it's our homeland
sunflower is a symbol of ukraine
so it's quite important because of the
war
right now
right now it's
very important for us to be united with
our friends with our family and with our
community
russia is not only waging
a physical war in ukraine by an
informational one as well and i think
it's really important to know what is
going on there
down at the russian embassy it's not
only ukrainians there are lots of other
people who actually come there and
support
you could support you could donate
just help ukraine because
we don't want to be taken over by russia
it's nice to know in ukraine people who
are there that all over the world there
are people who are going to support them
there are people who are standing with
them every step of the way because if
i'm just standing there listening all
i'm going to do is worry but if i come
here and if i try and help if i try and
donate if i try and protest if i try and
make posters it feels like you're doing
something you're actually helping
and that makes you feel a bit better
[Music]
but it's not just ukrainian families
that live in the uk there are thousands
of russian families that live here too
now many of them are against the war but
they're worried that russian children
will be discriminated against or bullied
at school because of the war
we've had lots of questions come in from
fy viewers who would like advice about
this we're joined by child psychologist
laverne antrobus to answer some of your
concerns thank you for joining us
laverne thank you for having me so lots
of us know people from ukrainian or
russian families but we're not too sure
what to say to them like kira who sent
us this question
what should we say to people at school
who have russian or ukrainian families
thank you kyra that's a really
thoughtful question i mean it is
complicated isn't it when you're faced
with these very difficult situations but
i suppose you know what we do know is
that the russian president and his
generals have invaded ukraine it's not
necessarily as we know something that
all russians support and so being on
hand for both sets of your friends is
really important so what do you do if
someone's being bullied or making an
inappropriate comment about the war
i think that there's nothing that's
changed about bullying you have to call
it out you have to talk to your parents
or to your teachers about this but i
think you've also got to remember to
talk to the person that's being bullied
and offer them your support and as for
inappropriate comments i mean i'd want
people to feel that they could be sort
of have a bit of authority here to say
that's not helpful you know this is a
really difficult time that people are
going through so let's all think about
what we say because our words do have an
impact well that's really great advice
so our next question is from seraphina
what do you do when the news is just
upsetting you so much
thanks seraphina gosh really really
important question isn't how do you stay
informed and involved but also look
after yourself i think it's about
choosing your news very carefully maybe
checking in in the right places so fyi
is a brilliant place i think there are
some ordinary things to remember you
know taking yourself off social media
just before bedtime you don't want to go
to bed with sort of lots of overwhelming
thoughts in your minds and i think
alongside that you know sometimes we can
stumble across things just accidentally
that really are quite distressing and
quite upsetting so if that happens you
know talk to somebody about it so that
you're not having to manage this sort of
awful images that can sort of take up
our minds um on your own so talk to a
parent or talk to your friends i'm sure
a lot of what you've said there has been
really helpful for loads of viewers
watching this now so thank you so much
for your advice and thank you so much
for your time well thanks for having me
well we know that the worst situations
like war can also bring out the best in
people and people all over the world are
standing with ukraine
regular view with pictures of everyone
coming together in the hope that soon
there will be peace
[Music]
you